blaues meer strand sonne alles wie immer
in antalya nur die zehn millionen
urlauber die sich sonst ihr tummeln viel
die regierung versucht mit allen mitteln
zu verhindern dass auch dieser sommer
ins wasser fällt
wir begleiten den reiseführer für wen er
ins krankenhaus
zu seiner zweiten corona schutzimpfung
der in hotels oder reiseagenturen
arbeitet hat höchste priorität egal
welches alter eine der vielen maßnahmen
um wieder touristen ins land zu holen
und tausende beschäftigte wie ufuk aus
der kurzarbeit
ich denke das ganze tourismus ist sehr
sehr wichtig und ja und man kommt auch
sehr schnell voran mit der infos
am flughafen antalya kommen trotz aller
anstrengungen nur wenige maschinen aus
bulgarien
der ukraine auch aus deutschland
familie tucson aus nürnberg hat sich
trotz corona auf den weg gemacht
wir haben einen vertrauensbonus dass die
hier gehen die vorschriften eingehalten
werden der mann muss es wissen er
betreibt selbst zu hause in nürnberg
eine reinigungsfirma das konzept hier in
antalya sagt ramazan tucson habe ihnen
überzeugt
wer jetzt in den großen hotels urlaub
macht der hat viel platz viel mehr als
üblich die anlagen sind nicht einmal zur
hälfte belegt also es ist hier sehr
professionell aufgebaut die
hygienevorschriften sind wirklich sehr
sehr gut an jeder ecke an jedem tisch
sind desinfektionsmittel die mitarbeiter
verteilen masken und belehren auch
diejenigen die vielleicht vergessen mal
die massen aufzuziehen
schon im letzten corona sommer hatten
die hotels umfangreiche hygiene
standards eingeführt temperaturmessungen
per kamera am eingang
sicherheitsabstände am buffet wo
personal mit handschuhen bedient selbst
zugreifen verboten sollte es doch zu
infektionen kommen bieten die hotels
kostenlose quarantäne zimmer
trotzdem wird die türkei mit täglich
7000 gemeldeten corona infektionen
weiter als hoch inzidenz
der rückreise heißt das auch für usb und
christopher aus essen quarantäne
das nehmen sie im café für uns ist es
kein problem ich meinen momentan ist es
sowieso so das haupt sich hier vom
home-office gearbeitet wird man sowieso
nicht vor die tür tritt sag ich mal und
das ist ganz gut überprüfe pcr-test
quarantäne auflagen
derzeit komme nur wenige deutsche russen
oder briten an die türkischen strände
obwohl die behörden massivem
werbeaufwand betreiben der tourismus ist
dutzend der botschafter aus der
hauptstadt ankara und die internationale
presse nach antalya zur hochglanz
präsentation
[Musik]
das ziel ist klar die türkei so schnell
wie möglich von der roten risikoliste
holen die botschaft urlaub lässt sich
die branche ist mit zehn prozent des
inlandsprodukts ein wichtiger
bestandteil der angeschlagenen
türkischen eine sonderbehandlung für
urlaubsgäste findet nicht nur rang in
einer sorgfältig inszenierten fernseh
diskussion mit studenten präsident
erdogan sich vorsichtige kritik im
laufstall mit dieser studenten touristen
sich bei willi vierhaus ihn zu hause
bleiben wird viel diskutiert was
einzuschätzen
die wenigen touristen die trotz corona
der zeit da sind haben ein risiko auf
sich genommen
sollen wir diesen besuchern jetzt sagen
ihr dürft nicht auf die straße gehen
wenn sie drei oder fünf euro oder dollar
in unser land bringen
dann sollten wir sie noch daran hindern
wie groß die krise ist sieht man abseits
der luxuriösen fünf sterne häuser die
kleinen oft familiengeführten hotels
können sich teure hygiene zertifikate
nicht leisten
die herrscht flaute und arbeitslosigkeit
htg und hassan posten verloren im
letzten jahr ihre hotel jobs mit einer
kleinen teestube wollten sie sich über
wasser halten
aber das läuft in zeiten von
ausgangspunkt nicht gut die schulden
häufen sich und da sie wie viele saison
arbeiter nicht sozialversichert sind den
sie auch beim kurzarbeitergeld lernens
[Musik]
eigentlich hätte ich an gesetzlichen
abfindung bei der entlastung erhalten
die versicherung zahlt auch nicht vom
staat gibt es keine unterstützung von
diesen sorgen sind die gäste nebenan im
tennis resort weit entfernt neben seinen
urlaubern trainieren hier gerne sportler
viele aus osteuropa corona schreckt
niemanden ab familie besser aus dresden
ist schon zum zweiten mal da einige sind
geimpft die anderen müssen nach der
rückreise zu hause in quarantäne oder
momentan bisschen schwierig weil diese
verordnung sehr undurchsichtig sind
ich habe da sehr oft mit dem
gesundheitsamt informiert und irgendwann
konnten sie mir so einigermaßen sagen
wie es ist wir lassen uns überraschen
es wird hotelbesitzer kämmerlein gibt
sich trotz aller hürden optimistisch
finanziell kann der schwerreiche
textilunternehmer der einst den aachen
studierte die durststrecke überstehen
tennis und das hotel sind praktisch sein
hobby er vertraut darauf dass die
deutschen diesen sommer wiederkommen
wir haben gäste die 66 70 mal hierher
gekommen sind und die können darauf
nicht verzichten
also wie ich erwarte auf irgendwann im
juli ab juli mindestens 500 600 gäste
von russland
noch aber ist es nicht soweit wehrt sich
in spanien und griechenland die strände
schon wieder füllen schwankten die
menschen in antalya noch zwischen hoffen
und bangen
[Musik]